if we have anybody who's Shakespeare in
our time it's Dylan
and he just speaks to me more and more
and he once said in an interview that
the the purpose of art was to inspire
and when you see a Dylan show you would
think he's so good you know if you go
see a jazz cat who's so good playing
bass you can leave that show going why
do we even pick up a bass again but for
some reason and I'm not the only one
that feels this at the end of the Dylan
show art just seems so good
I want to go write a play I'll write a
novel I'll stay up all night write a
song and you don't care that it's not
it's not as good the other thing I love
about Dylan is he is a freak not a
cheerleader when you go see Springsteen
it's all this inclusive stuff you know
don't we all love girls and cars and
don't we all have an economic downturn
don't we all want justice and we're all
here and yeah oh and let's go and it's
this feeling of camaraderie the whole
show everybody's Bruce Springsteen and
you might want to make comparisons
between Springsteen and Dylan and I
think it'd be completely wrong because
even if they both have gravelly voices
and both come from the same traditions
he's a cheerleader and that's good
nothing wrong with that but Dylan just
stands there and says I am speaking for
me maybe some of this is true for you
too I don't know but I'm digging so deep
all of his mining you know is going
towards his heart and deeper into his
brain he makes no attempt that I can
tell to say oh yeah this is going to
kill him yeah this is what they'll like
and that's where universality has to
live you can't be Universal if you're
trying to please other people you could
only be universal if you have so clearly
who you are and Dylan has no idea who he
is but he's still searching and he's
sharing that process with us
and you know people tell me you know
you're such a Dylan nut what album
should I listen to and I always tell
them stay with the 21st century you
don't even need to go before that who
else and I would throw in Chronicles is
probably the most I I think it's less
fully realized beat praiseful that I
know and read about who are really
literary they will always come up with
Shakespeare burns Dylan The Velvet
Underground were this dirt dumb
banging Punk with an Aaron Copland
scholar
playing viola over it and with you know
Delmore Schwartz short story type lyrics
all kind of mixed together that war
whole thing of is this really stupid or
is this really smart that mixing I am a
complete and utter sucker for